[Music]
thank you okay everybody settle down
settle down we are here for our first
meeting to discuss
this new Air Force project I know
there's been lots of questions since our
debrief and I want to get through as
many as we can today please stick your
questions in the comments we'll try and
get through them so first of all can we
please
get out of the way no this isn't a joke
no it's not a practical joke from the
London office over here this is real I
don't want to see any more comments
about whether this is a joke or not it's
the biggest account that we've ever had
the most difficult account we've ever
had we do really need to try to come up
with a solution to some of these very
very difficult and world changing
questions that we've been asked to
put a positive spin on when the US
government revealed this to the public
it's going to change everything the
world is going to change overnight and
we have been asked to participate in a
massive part of that you guys should be
excited ecstatic to be involved in
something that will seriously and
honestly change the entire planet
forever so come on guys let's get our
thinking caps on let's start that big
thinking and let's start trying to come
up with a solution to some of these
problems that I know I know you've
already raised this really is the
biggest challenge there is a lot of
science involved in this there's a lot
of stuff that's really going to go over
people's heads so how is the best way to
get the science across in a way that
people are going to understand but also
more importantly is not going to scare
them to death we need to try to figure
out what are the priorities that people
are actually going to focus on
so for me the first priority the people
are really going to focus on and that
will Panic people is the safety are my
family safe are my children safe am I
safe
is the world safe because of the
Stargate project and let's be honest
within a little bit of a snag on that
one we really do need to avoid phrases
like end of the world
invasion
enslavement
massive risk that nearly ended the world
repeatedly I mean all right we we've
read the reports and a lot of this stuff
is going to get out
but at the end of the day it seemed like
on a weekly basis in almost every planet
these people ever visited
there seem to be a massive problem that
nearly either killed them or killed us
or killed everybody so that is a problem
so how do we turn that problem into a
solution this is the question that I'm
asking you guys to really get stuck into
we need to know how to phrase this in a
way that's going to excite people
instead of terrify them to their very
course
the next big bit that I think people are
really going to focus on is the aliens
exist now again we've hit a little bit
of a snag here because it does seem that
none of these aliens are cute and cuddly
none of them
I mean the main go award alien that
we're going to be talking about a lot
and again we really need to steer away
from the fact that we don't know where
most of these goals are and they seem to
an awful lot of them seem to be on earth
who we need to spin that somehow
um but the fact that they are snakes
that borrow into the back of our heads
and take over us
we need to figure out how to avoid that
anybody that thinks of a solution for
that one's getting a bottle of the best
Brandy because I'm struggling
we have lots of aliens out there that
are bigger than us stronger than us
better than us and actually seemingly
quite like to eat us
that is something again
is going to win you a bottle of brandy
if you can figure out how to get around
that one
a lot of them are dead now
there's that but the real problem is we
don't have an alien that we can stick on
a lunchbox
the Asgard seemed to be the closest
thing to that and you know like Grays
and all that it's kind of already
ingrained in our society I think people
have accepted them
they're virtually all dead
problem
but guys go through all these Mission
logs trying to find an alien we can
stick on a lunchbox for God's sake if we
can't sell them
people will freak out
so we need sex
tokra Good Start we need something that
we can turn into a teddy bear and sell
and we need something that we can
normalize that people will connect to
that again
won't scare the bejesus out of everyone
just just one just give me one
less of a problem is that the government
lied to us for 20 years we've kind of
already sorted that
because everyone kind of already knows
that so I don't think that's something
we need to kind of focus on too much the
conspiracy theorists have been out there
actually telling people exactly what's
been going on for 20 to 30 years and
obviously we've got Wormhole extreme
which kind of already told everybody
exactly what was happening
I think we could spin that in a yeah we
weren't telling you because we were
protecting you you know because of the
massive danger that we've already
mentioned
we might need to think of a way of
avoiding that as well that we don't want
to remind people about the massive
Danger
that we already mentioned
but in a way that allows us to say we
were protecting them
another big problem
how are the world's religions going to
act to these Revelations how do we
soften the blow to them
a lot of people's fundamental beliefs
are going to get rocked to the core when
this gets announced
how do we stop them just going crazy
a lot of them have based their entire
lives on the principles that we're then
going to say
was actually just an alien pretending to
be a god
so
we're gonna have to think of a way of
sort of framing that
in a way that allows them to still
believe in the things they need to
believe in while understanding what
they're being told
and hopefully
not too many of them will throw
themselves off buildings or go and run
pages
or just sit in their beds for the next
two years and not do anything
yeah
if we can figure out at least one
religion that we can get on board with
this
Buddhists maybe or something that could
be the spokesperson for that guys again
we need a strategy for that start
putting your thinking caps on
one religion if we get one religion on
board
maybe we can sort of mitigate the
problems that's going to cause
lastly come on guys we need a face for
this we need somebody to stick on the
poster
if we don't have a face somebody that
can stand up there some of the people
can trust
then we are going to have a real problem
so obviously
one of the team from sg1 would be the
most obvious for us to use and you guys
have suggested that already but again
some of you have pointed out a few
problems so O'Neill was one of the most
influential people in a lot of the early
reports that we've read he then got
promoted and actually commanded the SGC
for quite a while so he would be really
important
a few of you have pointed out his
sarcasm might not come across well while
we're trying to keep a lid on this and
stop too many people from panicking
so
we might have to put a pin in that
Samantha Carter is probably the next
most influential person in this she is
very eloquent she's very pretty she'll
look good on a poster
we are gonna have to figure out how to
sidestep questions about her blowing up
Stars
and planets quite as often as she does
but we can we can try and spin that
Daniel Jackson is not a military person
he would look great on the poster and
having somebody that isn't part of the
military would be really really useful
for large sections of the population
that are going to be kind of freaked out
than the military have been running this
and handing out weapons to every planet
they've come across
and the blowing up Stars thing
so Daniel's action would be great
we're gonna have a little bit of a
problem in trying to explain why he's
died so many times
that's gonna there's gonna be questions
about that
if we can have an answer to those
questions that would be great
forget tilk
even though having an alien face on this
it's not teal
nah
as I said guys we need to start thinking
of some positive solutions to these
problems
stop freaking out stop panicking
do your jobs do what you're good at we
have been doing this for governments and
companies for decades they
pollute a nation kill hundreds we focus
on their profits or we spin it to make
it look like it was someone else's fault
we're good at this stuff we're really
good at making a massive pile of turds
look like fertilizer so come on
let's start doing what we do best people
ask us when we figure out how to put a
positive spin on this and the government
released this massive Secret
you are going to have achieved something
you've never achieved before it's going
to be the greatest achievement of your
life so come on let's get excited let's
trigger our imaginations let's put our
heads together and start thinking some
big answers to these big questions
because this is why we got into this
business this is why you are PR people
this is why you earn the big money so
get on it guys you can do this I believe
in you
come on
somebody think of something please
[Music]